[Musique]
à côté de cet aspect sportif gravitent
vous le savez tout un folklore du tour
et puis derrière le peloton des
cyclistes se profile l'imposante la très
imposante caravane publicitaire
d'ailleurs les véritables amoureux de la
petite reine déplore que la compétition
proprement dite soit en quelque sorte
étouffé par tout ce tintamarre publicit
aux publicités commerciales
près de 8000 personnes dans une commune
qui en contient habituellement la moitié
des restaurants qui affichent complet
malgré des prix eux aussi majorer des
touristes qui désertent la plage malgré
la canicule saint pierre d'oléron a
prêté l'espace de quelques heures ces
artères à la grande foire du tour de
france
les odeurs d'ambré solaire à bon marché
quelques peaux grasses ou rougi par le
soleil c'est l'ambiance habituelle du
tour de france avec son incroyable
envahissement de publicité de chapeau
lessive à disait tout assurant sans
oublier bien sûr le traditionnel clip
alors que les coureurs exhibent leurs
mollets sur des routes surchauffées le
public que ce mas lui derrière des
grillages sur la ligne d'arrivée c'est
la chasse aux cacahuètes publicitaire
jeté avec plus ou moins de nonchalance
par les eaux au fil de la caravane
[Musique]
approchez approchez messieurs dames un
échantillon gratuit de chocolat pour le
monsieur au chaperon un sachet de
lessive en poudre pour la dame en
décolleté le sport cycliste a décidément
quelques vertus cachées
[Musique]
n'allez pas croire pour autant que les
enfants sont les seuls à quémander des
porte-clés les adultes aussi jouent des
coudes piétine pouce pour arracher le
trésor fabuleux en plastique met aux
couleurs du tour qui trônera bientôt
dans la salle à manger du f3 de banlieue
c'est le cirque ou presque sur la route
du tour et les équilibristes roule pour
vous c'est encore et toujours du
matraquage publicitaire cette publicité
indispensable à la survie du tour de
france innove et abreuvent les
spectateurs derrière leurs grilles
toutes ces mains tendues donc quand même
qu'un lointain rapport avec le sport
cycliste
c'est vrai
[Musique]